[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien extra médian tu pouvais pas lui
mettre savant 1
c'est là tu pouvais pas le même temps je
suis pas respirer tout va t il ma vallée
de la dore seca mire et camier
d'amérique hier au soir mon chéri vous
avez 24 ans télé tout ce qu'il fallait
pas rater à la télé à la tête
aujourd'hui mais très vite passe
aujourd'hui tout va à 100 à l'heure il
ya plus de sous en boîte on peut plus et
fleurs et maternité et on a des images
qu'ils appellent emboîtables allait
aller en boîte ce week end avec son mari
auquel woods a lyon quelques mois je
suis athée au bois des rêves aucun on a
les images d'isabelle en bois doré noir
et blanc je me demande c'est peut-être
la meilleure des missions basées ici ici
ainsi par oui non mais c'est normal
quand on fait sens il ya beaucoup de
déchet mais y en a une qui tombent chez
dodge et des dossiers sur laquelle auch
ce soir là devant un peu son instagram
il s'en passe de belles eaux apparemment
même la détox les bonnes portes et
laisser parti reste on a vu aujourd'hui
rester dans les marseillais julien tanit
il est en pleine préparation mariage fut
la soirée de la veille je préfère pas
être invité ces bons notamment de
négation de la fête de l'eau oui
d'accord ok
dervin deux garçons en russie toutes les
chaînes info retransmis l événement très
sérieux le premier drone de la poste
là-bas qui peut livrer les colis
directement à la maison ivre et devant
la maison on assiste aux premières en
volant dire avec toutes les télés sont à
fond c'est magique c'est magique c'est
pas le super et non plus sinon dans la
matinale de lci l'invité parfait à 7h du
mat pour aller travailler bonjour michel
quidoz est le nom de la fédération
européenne tient cyril féraud a toujours
le même assistant pour ces fiches que
vous serrez d'amendé un directeur
d'école maternelle non à des nouvelles
de notre ancien président il s'est lancé
dans leur aréna d'abord sonné ce garçon
regardez comme il est doux et ilaria
méthode pour péter les falaises et
regarder l'autre ancien président il
s'est lancé dans le rack visiblement ça
fait un moment que c'était dans les
tuyaux la retrouver sur un stade
[Musique]
c'est lorenzo on dira m on dirait c'est
un mélange entre madoff le président il
ya du malheur du 2 et du madoff
j'ai maté les jt aussi huawei alors les
flécher les journaux télévisés cesser
les journaux télévisés bas à mon pote
c'est un truc de fou
alors déjà je suis hyper content a pris
des nouvelles d'un copain convoi pour
moi en ce moment mais apparemment c'est
parce qu'il est sur ces news je trouve
qu'on le voit pas assez
c'est notre poteau issa doumbia
visiblement il est moins là il préfère
parler foot sur ces news oui ça donne a
été dépouillé comme le dj ce titre
d'ailleurs déclaré jc news pour sa
débrancher micro-antennes faso
l'attentant toutes les galères of thé
avec eux bien que ce soit une grève
perlée vous le savez qui dure dix huit
jours avec 18 jours de préavis et puis
en fait non ce sera sur les feuilles de
paye des grévistes pour ça marche avec
lui me liait qui tu en voilà leur
diagonale qui nous rapatrier à laurent
guyot
ce matin jean jacques baudet recevait la
ministre chargée des transports il avait
deux bornes et jean-jacques quand il
pose une question il veut une réponse il
h pas le morceau est elle justifiée
cette grève je dis clairement un
personne ne peut comprendre je vous ai
posé une question est ce qu'elle est
justifiée je voudrais revenir peut-être
donc moment donné n'est pas justifiée
moi je pense qu'au japon que la grève
est injustifiée
moi je suis à l'endroit une douzaine
dans une question est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
cette grève vous parle justifié amis ou
non moi j'entends qu'il peut y avoir des
craintes donc pas justifié j'ai bien
compris il faut poursuivre le dialogue
n'est pas justifié pour
réponse donc il est parti sur la dette
aux délires la dette l'encore et en
toupie le jrs qu'avant la fin du
quinquennat
cette dette de 45 milliards d'euros sera
effacée l'état aura repris cette dette
est une dette qui pourrait être reprise
l'état reprend la dette
donc là les oreilles face et donc la
dette sera effacé la dette sera effacée
tu crois que tu va [ __ ] mais en fait
tu n'y pas j'ai regardé les émissions d'
aventure aussi est notamment avant koh
lanta j'ai maté wide aussi sur m6 ouais
je sais a fait pipi dans l'âme j'ai vu
j'ai vu lors des débuts de polémiques
tanga pense à tanga est donc là j'ai
l'impression quand même la voix off en
début d'émission tu as l'impression il
parle de tpm paie un peu au début rires
des ciels c'est la voix off de why de
regarder une température de plus de 40
degrés un taux d'humidité supérieur à
90% dhr si on change d images ça colle
avec tpm fait à merveille
ampera tueur de plus de 40 degrés un
taux d'humidité supérieur à 90% des
cougars et plus de 2 millions d'espèces
d'insectes le
un univers où très peu d'hommes ont mis
les pieds si l'on a trouvé le service le
service hyper gênante et demandé la
candidate et gêne était gêné devant ta
télé via que le gars qui capte pas la
gêne c'est original quoi je peux tenir
le coup et je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé dans koh lanta faudrait vraiment
qu'ils y pensent à trouver un patron
parce qu'ils cherchent tous un patron
dans koh lanta parle
[Applaudissements]
patron c'est toi alors j'allais d'accord
j'ai fait un peu le tour d un style ram
de l'équipe alors penché sur l'instinct
g de de là qu'est l'os et ouais mais tu
es b avant je suis allé sur instagram de
bernard montiel jean-marc un truc déjà
voilà première nouvelle folie et faut
digérer la madame vous m'avez bernard
montiel il a un instinct grand-père
dames auquel il a un instinct gras et
nos jours on va voter dans sa grotte et
il a un truc c'est je pense en vrai en
vrai de vrai je pense il est tombé
amoureux de kelly mais pas dans un
délire de pécho alors amoureux je tenais
de lure frère que c'est vrai
et moi je les vois je vous le dis je
vous jure je les vois en coulisse
barbelés voit ici je te jure frérot
comme c'est un ado 4e b les amoureux
mais vraiment de quel juge en a deux qui
sont amoureux de tennis il ya mathieu
delormeau et bernard montiel on n'aurait
pas misé sur les noms au départ c'est
vrai que tu me voilà c'est pas les deux
premières personnes qui viennent à
l'esprit
bernard arrêt on a douze mois à issoire
organise une bouée dit il c'est quoi
c'est pas de l'amour
il sait que s'il te kiffe samecki mais
je vais qui fascine mais s'il fait très
jeune
ah oui c'est vrai il écrit à moi est
très bon il est vrai pas tu dises et
périph
[Musique]
on va les regarder justement chaque fois
que bernard montiel vient dans tpm t il
en a rien à [ __ ] de vos gueules bois
que kelly il se trouve toujours des
petits stratagèmes de qui s'est
d'ailleurs ses cheveux
[Rires]
c'est nous qui avons chaque direct voilà
ce qui se passe en loge il possède deux
instagram ça c'est fort la grappe d'or a
manqué loyer qu'il n'ya pas d'un
quartier sensible
vidéo
je vis ici mon coeur pas plus fort parce
que je sais que je vais te voir qu'un
modèle dimanche si tu manges on nous
montre le père et bernard qui fait
normal je suis branché pour séduire sa
belle soeur ma jolie kelly de l'huma
prendre le dise le mieux le vieux le
werder elle seule chaîne de salles de
briques dengue de type web mathieu non
mais après bernard c'est pas le prénom
le plus sensuel pour battu une fois
battus 6 ans n'a pas dit la vérité toi
choisir entre bernard et moi regarder de
maître bernard largement pour une nuit
mais jamais de la vie avec toi
[Applaudissements]
tempérament bras oui apparemment faut
pas la faire chier que son champ de blé
sur la tête et ce chan de blé dans
lequel elle est plus dans le haut je
suis tombé sur tu t'es détox par hasard
dans le voilà dans sa cuisine vraiment
l'air de rien on s'amusait à refaire les
photos avec moctar dans ce que ça
pourrait donner en public dans la
cuisine notamment les photos elles sont
belles on dirait une pause devant le
décret devant le four à gâteau koné
gâteau comme péter kox avec le som petit
béret on la refait tes conneries c'est
pas mal mais ma préférée c'est la plus
naturelle c'est la pause canapé bien sûr
pour vendu tu es et là c'est vraiment
c'est parfait
[Applaudissements]
bravo tout cas ses ciels vénale ça
valait pas mieux c'est pire qu'au mans a
battu à ce niveau là allez merci et
médée de l'ars a suffi d'un gène ont
construit leur toit la téloche nana il
reçoit taylor animaux tvc j'en bouffe
mais toute la journée et cette semaine
dernière sauvait le chanteur dave alors
il reçoit pour raconter des grands
comptes un petit peu des anecdotes
mignonne sur ces animaux là toujours
aimé les animaux dave est comment dire
il aurait peut-être dû consulter
wikipedia dave avant parce que c'est pas
hyper guéant fait ce qu'ils avaient créé
un pool qui perd déchets plumé la poule
ont essayé de l'assassiner
puis il ya ça fait écraser par un bus si
je jouais cochons d'inde mais avec de la
paille se sont entretués je me suis
malheureusement il est mort en chutant
d'un crise cardiaque vous avez une très
très belle histoire avec les animaux etc
j'ai aussi ma télé marseille et fera t
on chez sika n'a rien compris à
l'expression rire jaune
je lui dis la vérité
mais c'est quoi qui donne jaune
et sinon pendant une visite d'une maison
de disques américaine les anges sont
tombés sur un grand nom de la musique
française ça les a portés
faux
[Musique]
j'ai maté jeu télé aussi matin peut
jeter comme tous les jours nouvelle
candidate dans des chiffres et des
lettres c'est sandra et je vous rassure
on se dit des fois à peut-être qu'ils
des chiffres et des lettres ils n'ont
pas d'autres trucs à côté pas du tout en
dehors de l'émission elle passe des
week-ends de housses jean-mi est pas
prêt de la croiser en boîte celle ci
nous être fidèles alors je sais que vous
c'est un peu atypique vous nous regardez
le le week-end de travailler exactement
et du coup le week-end je fais les cinq
triplés de la semaine c'est après que
c'était pour et d'allusions dans des
chiffres et des lettres et husson qu'ils
ont pas l'habitude donc le moindre petit
truc ça met tout le monde mal à l'aise
au plateau on n'est pas bons on a écouté
au moins on appris quelque chose ça vous
risquiez c'est pas les mêler de la
lettre bien sûr avec nous jenner danse
la monique respecte pas le matos c'est
le fola bailey rae carneiro a trouvé
dans faster de chris marques avoue cyril
il est charmant celle d'un danseur à
deux papas danseurs là
[Applaudissements]
bercy j'aime bien ce gars j'ai maté du
foot à un petit peu de foot
juste avant la finale avec quelques
images de la finale de la coupe de la
ligue on a trouvé une équipe qui était
vraiment à fond pendant l'hymne si on
peut voir surtout un gars qui
visiblement a bien kiffé l'ailier droit
cependant tous les mineurs non quand
même l vas-y vas-y
c'est le genre de livre bien sûr sinon
pendant la finale regarder on a vu
l'enfant trop content de passer à la
télé très à l'aise de fass cannes une
fois et deux fois il y aura les dit
tour de vis perval ronaldo sélectionnés
français
on a aussi eu une pensée pour ceux
supporters du psg qui allait jusqu'à
bordeaux pour encourager son équipe il a
poussé des coudes pour approcher les
joueurs et il se prend une ignorance
16000 de dani alves
hélas cette expression de loups de
consommation nos jeunes un peu parce que
des vols le faut et à la fin on sait pas
pourquoi cavaliers pastore sont restés
longtemps sur le terrain faire coup
concédant au barça sur la base
ah ah
[Rires]
on va quitter on va se quitter avec un
mec qui est super fier c'est très très
fier c'est l'homme qui se fait péter
pour la première fois une suite dans un
cinq étoiles et il est hyper aux records
[Musique]
tél